[Musique]
sur cette séquence je vais vous montrer
la conduite à tenir face à une personne
qui a une obstruction complète des
voisins aériennes tout en mangeant
j'arrive près de la victime et là la
victime a les mains à la gorge à la
bouche ouverte il y a aucun son qui
sorte Matteo tu m'entends à ce moment-là
je vais laisser dans la position où il
se trouve pourra régir plus rapidement
je vais le pencher en avant tout en le
soutenant pour faciliter la sortie du
corps étranger et avec le talon de la
main je vais taper entre les omoplates
vigoureusement naturellement là je mime
jusqu'à 5 fois maximum si au bout de 5
fois c'est sorti on va le rassurer et
appeler si c'est pas sorti il faut
passer à une autre technique donc tout
en laissant la victime dans la position
où je l'ai trouvé je vais mettre à sa
même hauteur derrière elle passer mes
bras sous ses bras et mon point le dos
de la main vers le ciel je vais le
positionner juste au dessus du nombril
à votre ma part dessus mes bras écartés
et là en étant contre la chaise pour
avoir un plan dur je vais tirer vers moi
et remonter ce geste là va compresser
les poumons et donc faciliter la sortie
du corps étranger par un effet piston et
donc là la deuxième pareil 5 fois 2e
fois crash voilà et tout ça
la victime tous elle est sortie
d'affaires on va la rassurer ne
t'inquiète pas ce qui t'empêchait de
respirer et sorti d'accord tu risques
plus rien ça va tu respires mieux ok bon
ben voilà et pour avoir un avis médical
car seul le médecin peut faire un
diagnostic et bien je vais téléphoner et
avoir un avis pas forcément pour qui se
déplace mais pour avoir un avis médical